So in case you are all
worried that you may not
be in the right class,
you are still in 6.033.
If you're wondering
what happened
to the Indian guy who
normally lectures,
he's sitting right over there.
We are trading off lectures
throughout the class.
I'm going to do about
the next eight lectures
up until spring break, and
then Hari will be back.
So, my name is
Sam, and feel free
to address any questions
about the lecture to me.
So today we are
going to keep talking
about this concept of enforcing
modularity that we started
talking about last time.
So last time we saw how we could
use this notion of the client
service model in
order to separate
two modules from each other.
So the idea was by running
the client and the service
on separate machines, we
can isolate these two things
from each other.
So we can make it so, for
example, when the client wants
to invoke some
operation on the server,
that the server can verify the
request that the client makes,
and make sure that the
client isn't asking
to do something malicious.
Similarly, so this is what we
saw last time was this client
service model.
And so the other benefit
of the client service model
was it meant that
we could decouple
the client from the service.
So it meant that when the
client issued a request
against the service,
it didn't necessarily
mean that the client, if
the service failed when
the client issued the
request, it wasn't necessarily
the case that the
client would also fail.
So the server might crash
executing the request,
and then the client
would get a timeout
and would be able to retry.
And similarly, if
the client failed,
the server could continue
handling requests
on the behalf of other clients.
OK, so that was a nice
separation, the ability
to split the client and the
server apart from each other.
That's a good thing.
But the problem
with this approach
is that we had to have
two separate machines.
The way we presented this was
that the client was running
on one computer,
and the server was
running on another computer.
And if you think
about this, this
isn't exactly what
we want, right?
Because that means,
suppose we want
to build up a big, complicated
computer system that's composed
of multiple different modules.
If we have to run each
one of those modules
on a separate computer, that's
not really very ideal, right?
To build up a big
service, we're going
to need a whole
lot of computers.
And clearly, that's not the
way that computer systems
that we actually
interact with work.
So what we've seen so
far is this notion:
we have a module per computer.
OK, and what we're
going to do today
is see how we can
generalize this
so that instead of having
one module per computer,
we can instead have
multiple modules running
within a single computer.
But when we do
that, we still want
to maintain these nice
sort of protection benefits
that we had between
the client and service
when these two things were
running on separate computers.
OK, so the way we
are going to do
that is by creating something
we call a virtual computer.
So -- What we're going to do
is we're going to create this
notion of multiple
virtual computers.
They're all running on
one single computer.
And then we're going to run
each one of these modules
within a virtual computer.
OK, and I'll talk
more about what
I mean by a virtual computer
throughout the next couple
of lectures.
But the idea is that a virtual
computer has exactly the same,
to a program that's
running on it,
a virtual computers
looks just like one
of these client or server
computers might have looked.
Now, in particular,
a virtual computer
has the same sorts
of abstractions
that we studied in the previous
lectures available to it
that a real computer has.
So a virtual computer
has a virtual memory --
-- and a virtual processor.
So, today what we're
going to talk about
is this notion of
a virtual memory.
And so you guys have
already probably seen
the term virtual
memory in 6.004.
So, the word should
be familiar to you.
And we're going to use
exactly the same abstraction
that we used in 6.004.
So we're just going to show
how this abstraction can
be used to provide this
protection between the client
and server that we want.
OK, we're also going to
introduce today this notion
of something called a kernel.
And a kernel is something
that's in charge, basically,
of managing all of these
different virtual computers
that are running on our
one physical computer.
So the kernel is going to
be the sort of system that
is going to be the piece of
the system that actually knows
that there are multiple,
virtual computers running
on this system.
OK, so I want to start
off by first just talking
about why we want a virtualized
memory, why virtualizing
memory is a good thing.
So I'm going to abbreviate
virtual memory as VM.
So why would we want
to virtualize memory?
Well, let's see what might
happen if we build a computer
system with multiple
modules running on it
at the same time that didn't
have a virtualized memory.
So suppose we have
some microprocessor
and we have some memory.
And within this memory,
we have the code
and data for a couple of
different modules is stored.
So we have, say,
module A and module B,
and this is the things
like the code and the data
that these modules are
using to currently execute.
So, in this environment,
suppose the module, A,
executes some instruction.
So if you think
of this as memory,
let's say that module A
begins at address A here,
and module B begins
at address B here.
So, suppose that
module A executes
some instruction like store some
value, R1, in memory address,
B.
OK, so module A writes
into memory address B here.
So, this can be a
problematic thing,
right, because if the
microprocessor just
allows this to
happen, if it just
allows A to write into
module B's memory,
then module B has no
way of being isolated
from module A at all, right?
Module A can, for example,
write some sort of garbage
into the memory of module B.
And then when module B tries to
read from that memory address,
it will either, say, try and
execute an illegal instruction,
or it will read in some data
that doesn't make any sense.
So we've lost the
separation, the isolation
that we had between if module
A and module B are a client
and a service trying to
interact with each other.
We've lost this sort of ability.
We've lost the ability
to separate and isolate
each other, isolate
them from each other
that we had when they were
running on separate computers.
Furthermore, this sort of
arrangement of virtual memory.
So one problem with this is
A can overwrite B's memory.
But we have another
problem, which
is that this sort of
arrangement also is very, very
difficult to debug.
So, these kinds of bugs can
be very hard to track down.
And really, when we're
building computer systems,
we'd like to get rid of them.
So, for example, suppose that
A stores into B's memory,
overwrites an instruction that
somewhere sort of arbitrarily
within B's memory.
And then, 10,000
instructions later,
B tries to load in
that memory address
and execute that instruction.
And it gets an
illegal instruction.
Now, imagine that you have
to debug this program.
So you sort of
are sitting there,
and so you run application
B, and it works just fine.
And then you run application
A, and A overwrites part
of B's memory.
And now, when program
B runs sometimes
long after program A, perhaps,
is already terminated,
B mysteriously crashes on you.
So how are you going to
track down the problem?
It's very tricky, and
it's the kind of problem
that's extremely hard to
debug these kinds of issues.
So we really would
like to make it
so that A isn't able to
simply overwrite arbitrary
things into B's memory.
We'd like to protect A from B.
OK, and that's what this
virtual memory abstraction
that we're going to talk about
today is going to do for us.
So, if you think about how
you might protect A from B,
the solution that
you sort of come up
with after thinking
about this and staring
at this for a little
bit is that you
want to verify that
all of the memory
accesses that A does are
actually valid memory
accesses that A should
be allowed to make, so
for example, that refer to
objects that are actually
that A has allocated
or that A owns.
OK, so in order to do that,
what we're going to need to do
is to interpose some
sort of software
in between the memory accesses
that each module makes,
and the actual memory access.
So the idea is as follows.
So this is the virtual
memory abstraction.
OK, so the idea is as follows.
For each one of our
modules, say A and B,
we're going to create what's
known as an address space, OK?
And this address space is
going to be, for example,
on a 32 bit computer, it's
two to the 32 minus one,
it's going to be a
32 bit memory space.
So, this is the virtual address
space of, say, a process, A.
So, process A can use
any memory address
that's in this two to
the 32 bit range, OK?
But this is going to be
a virtual address space.
And what I mean by that
is when process A refers
to some address within
its memory space,
call it virtual address VA.
That address is going to be
mapped by the virtual memory
system into a
physical address, OK?
So this virtual address here
is going to be mapped into some
physical address --
-- somewhere within the actual
physical memory of the system,
OK?
So this physical memory of the
system is also a 32 bit space.
But the sort of mapping
from this virtual address
in A's memory into this
physical address space
is going to be handled by
this virtual memory system.
So now the idea is that
each thing that, say,
a process A or B might
want to reference
is going to be mapped into
some different location
within this memory.
So, for example, the code from
process A or from module A
can be mapped into one location,
and the code from module B
is going to be mapped
into a different location
in the physical address space.
OK, so we have this
notion of address spaces.
Each module that is running on
the system in a virtual memory
system is going to be allocated
to one of these address spaces.
This address space
is going to be,
and this address space
is virtual in the sense
that these addresses are
only valid in the context
of this given module, OK?
And, they translate into, each
address in the virtual space
translates into some address
in the physical space.
Now, if you look at
this for a minute,
you might think,
well, this is kind
of confusing because now B and
A both have a 32 bit address
space.
And the computer itself only
has a 32 bit address space.
So, there are sort
of more addresses
between all the modules than the
computer itself physically has.
And, if you remember back
from 6.004, the story
that we told you about
that was that, well,
some of these virtual
addresses can actually
be mapped into the
disk on the computer.
So in 6.004, virtual memory
was presented as a way
to create a computer
that appeared
to have more physical memory
than it, in fact, did.
And the way that
that was done was
to map some of these
addresses onto disk.
So you might have addresses
from B mapped onto disk.
And then, when B tries to
reference an address that's
mapped onto disk, the
system would load that data
from memory, load that data
from disk and into memory.
So, we're not going to
talk about that aspect
of virtual memory
very much today.
The thing to remember is just
that these virtual address
spaces, there may be parts
of this virtual address
space in each of
the modules that
isn't actually mapped into
any physical address space.
So if one of these
modules tries to use
one of these unmapped
virtual address spaces,
it's not allowed to do that.
This virtual memory system
will signal an error
when it tries to do that.
And on your computer,
sometimes you'll
see programs that
will mysteriously
crashed with things that say
things like, tried to access
an illegal memory address.
When it does that, that's
because the program
tried to access some memory
location that wasn't mapped
by the virtual memory system.
OK, so let's dive a
little more into actually
how this virtual memory
abstraction works
so we can try to understand
a little bit more
about what's going on.
So this is going to be a
simplified VM hardware, OK?
It's a little bit
simplified even
from what you learned
about in 6.004.
So, the idea in this
simplified hardware
is that we have our processor.
OK, and then we're going to
have this VM system, which
is sometimes called a
memory management unit, MMU.
And, this is a piece
of hardware that's
going to help us
to do this mapping
from these logical addresses
in the modules' address spaces
into the physical memory.
And then, we're going to
have the physical memory, OK?
Now the idea is that
when an instruction tries
to access some virtual
address, so for example
suppose we execute
instruction load
some virtual address, load into
R1 some virtual address, OK?
What's going to
happen when we do
that is that the
microprocessor is
going to send this virtual
address to the VM system.
And then the VM system is
going to translate that
into some physical address
that can be resolved
within the memory itself.
OK, and the way that the
virtual memory system is going
to decide this mapping
between a virtual address
and a physical address
is by using something
that we call a page map, OK?
OK, so this table is an example.
So this is a page map.
And what a page
map basically has
is its just a table of virtual
address to physical address
mappings.
So this is the virtual
address to physical address.
So the idea is that when some
virtual address comes in here,
the virtual memory
manager looks up
that virtual address
in this page map,
finds the corresponding
physical address,
and then looks that
physical address up
in the actual memory.
OK, so now there's one more
detail that we need, right?
So what this gives us is we
have this notion of a page map
that does this mapping for us.
But we're missing a
detail that is, OK,
what we wanted was for each
one of these different modules
that's running in the system
to have a different address
space associated with it.
So what we want is we
want to have separate page
maps for each of these different
modules, so, for A and B,
OK, we're going to have
a different page map.
And we're going to
have this sort of same,
we might have multiple copies
of a particular virtual address
in each one of these page maps.
And then what we're
going to do is
we're going to allocate
a special register
on the hardware,
on the processor.
We're going to add a
little register that's
going to allow us to keep track
of which one of these page maps
we are currently looking at, OK?
So this thing is called the
PMAR or the Page Map Address
Register.
OK, and the page
map address register
simply points at one
of these page maps.
OK, so what happens is that
the virtual memory system, when
it wants to resolve
a virtual address,
looks at this page
map address register
and uses that to find a pointer
to the beginning of the page
map that's currently in use.
And then he uses
the page map that's
currently in use
to resolve, to get
what physical
address corresponds
to this logical address.
OK so this is really the core
concept from virtual memory.
So what we have now is we have
this page map address register
that can be used to select which
one of these address spaces
we are currently using.
OK, and so when we have
selected, for example,
the page map for
module A, then module A
can only refer to
virtual addresses
that are in its page map.
And those virtual
addresses can only
map into certain
physical addresses.
So, for example,
suppose this block here
is the set of virtual addresses,
the set of physical addresses
that correspond to the virtual
addresses in A's page map.
OK, these are the only
physical addresses
that A can talk about.
So if we, for example, have
a different block of memory
addresses that correspond
to the virtual addresses
that B can reference,
we can see that there's
no way for module A to be able
to reference any of the memory
that B uses.
So we are able to
totally separate
the physical memory,
pieces of physical memory
that A and B can talk about by
using this page map mechanism
that virtual memory gives us.
So, basically what
we've done is we've
sort of added this extra
layer of indirection,
this virtual memory
system, that gets
to map virtual addresses
into physical addresses.
So the rest of this
lecture is really
going to be details about how
we make this work, about how
we actually decide, how we
assign this PMAR register based
on which one of the modules
is currently executing
about things like what the
format of this page map table
is going to look like, OK?
So this is really
the key concept.
So what I want to do
now is sort of turn
to this second question
I asked which is,
how does this page map
thing actually work?
How is it actually represented?
So one very simple
representation of a page map
might be that it
simply is a pointer to,
the page map just says where A's
memory begins on the processor,
right?
So it's just one value.
It says A's memory
begins at this location
in the physical memory,
and all virtual addresses
should be resolved
relative to this beginning
location of A's memory.
The problem with
that representation
is that it's not very flexible.
So, for example, suppose
there's a third module, C,
which is laid out in
memory right next So,
its storage is placed
right next to A in memory.
And now, suppose that A wants to
allocate some additional memory
that it can use.
Now, in order to do that,
if the page map is simply
a single pointer to the
beginning of A's address space,
we're kind of in trouble.
We can't just add
memory onto the bottom
because then we would overlap C.
So we're going to
have to move all
of A's memory around in order to
be able to make space for this.
OK, so this seems like a
little bit problematic simply
have it be a pointer.
The other thing we could do
is suppose we could, instead,
have a different option
where we could say,
for example, for every virtual
address in A's address space,
so for each 32 bit value
that A wants to resolve,
there might be an entry in
this page map table, right?
So for every 32-bit
virtual address,
there would be a corresponding
32-bit physical address.
And there would just
be a one-to-one mapping
between all these things.
So, if A could reference a
million blocks of memory,
there would be a million
entries in this page map table.
So, if you think about
this for a minute, that
sounds like kind
of a bad idea, too,
because now these tables
are totally huge, right,
and in fact they are
almost as big as the memory
itself, right, because if I
have a million entries, if A can
reference a million
blocks, then I'm
going to need a million
entries in the table.
So the table becomes just
as big as the memory itself.
So we need some in between
sort of alternative hybrid
between these two extremes.
And the idea, again,
is very simple.
And you saw it in 6.004.
So the idea is to take this
32-bit virtual address.
So suppose this is our
Now what we're
going to do is we're
going to split it up
into two pieces, a page
number and an offset.
OK, and we're going to choose
some size for these two things.
For now I'll just arbitrarily
pick a 20 bit page
number and a 12 bit offset.
OK, so what this is going to do,
so now what we're going to do
is instead of storing
a single word of memory
at each entry in
this table, we're
going to store a page of memory
at each entry in this table.
So -- So this table is going
to look like a mapping between
a page, and a physical address.
OK, so what a page is, so if
the page number is 20 bits long,
then that means
that each page is
going to be two to the 12th bits
big, which is equal to, say,
4,096 words, OK?
So the idea is that
we're going to have two
to the 20th pages within
each address space,
and each page is going to map to
one of these 4,096 byte blocks,
OK?
So, if we have our memory
here this page, say, page one
is going to map into
some physical address.
And page two is going to map
into some other physical block,
OK, so each one of these things
is now 4,096 bytes, each block
here, OK?
And so this, let's
just expand this.
So this is now a page.
And this 12 bit offset is
going to be used in order
to look up the word that
we want to actually look up
in this page.
So, if the virtual address
is, say, for example,
page one offset zero,
what that's going to do
is we're going to look
up in the page map.
We're going to find the page
number that corresponds to,
we're going to find
page number one.
We're going to find the physical
address that corresponds to it,
we're going to go down here, and
look at this block of memory.
And then within this
4,096 block memory,
we're going to take the
address zero, the first word
within that thing, OK?
So now the size of these page
tables is much smaller, right?
They're no longer
two to the 30th bits.
Now they're two
to the 20th bits,
which is some small
number of megabytes big.
But we've avoided this
problem that we have before.
We have some flexibility in
terms of how each page maps
into the physical memory.
So I can allocate a
third page to a process.
And I can map that
into any 4,096 byte
block that's in memory
that's currently unused.
OK, so I have flexibility.
I don't have this problem,
say, where A and C
were colliding with each other.
OK, so this is
sort of the outline
of how virtual memory works.
But what I haven't
yet described to you
is how it is that
we can actually
go about creating these
different address spaces that
are allocated to the
different modules,
and how we can switch between
different modules using
this PMAR register.
So I've sort of
described this as,
suppose these data
structures exist,
now here's how we can use them.
But I haven't told you how
these data structures all
get together, and created,
and set up to begin with.
And I hinted at this
in the beginning.
But in order to do this,
what we're going to need
is some sort of a special
supervisory module that's
able to look at the
page maps for all
of these different, that's
able to create new page maps
and look at the
page maps for all
of the different modules
that are within the system.
And the supervisory
module is going
to be able to do things like
add new memory to a page map
or be able to destroy,
delete a particular module
and its associated page map.
So we need some sort
of a thing that can
manage all this infrastructure.
So, this supervisory module --
-- is called the kernel.
OK, and the kernel
is really, it's
going to be the
thing that's going
to be in charge of managing all
these data structures for us.
So -- So here's our
microprocessor with its PMAR
register on it.
And, what we're
going to do is we're
going to extend the
microprocessor with one
additional piece of hardware,
and this is the user kernel
bit, OK?
So, this is just a bit specifies
whether we are currently
running a user module that
is just a program that's
running on your computer, or
whether the kernel is currently
executing, OK?
And the idea with
this kernel bit
is that when this kernel bit is
set, the code that is running
is going to have
special privileges.
It's going to be
able to manipulate
special things about the
hardware and the processor.
And in particular,
we're going to have
a rule that says that only the
kernel can change the PMAR, OK?
So the PMAR is the thing
that specifies which process
is currently running, and
selects which address space we
want to be currently using.
And what we're going to
use is we're going to use,
so what we're going to
do is have the kernel
be the thing that's in
charge of manipulating
the value of this PMAR
register to select which thing
is currently being executed.
And we want to make it so that
only the kernel can do this
because if we, for
example, allowed
one of these other programs to
be able to manipulate the PMAR,
right, then that
other program might
be able to do something
unpleasant to the computer,
right?
It changes the PMAR to point
at some other program's memory.
And now, suddenly all the
memory addresses in the system
are going to be resolved.
Then suddenly, we
are going to be
sort of resolving memory
addresses relative
to some other module's page map.
And that's likely to
be a problematic thing.
It's likely to cause that other
module to crash, for example,
because the processor is set
up to be executing instructions
from the current program.
So we want to make sure that
only something this kernel
can change the PMAR.
And this kernel is going to be
this sort of supervisory module
that all of the
other modules are
going to have to trust to
kind of do the right thing
and manage the computer's
execution for you.
And this kernel, except
for this one difference
that a kernel can
change the PMAR,
the kernel is, in
all other respects,
essentially just going to
be another module that's
running in the computer system.
So in particular,
the kernel is also
going to have one of these
32-bit virtual address
spaces associated with it, OK?
But, what we're
going to do is we're
going to say that the kernel
within its address space
has all of the page maps of
all the other programs that
are currently running on the
system mapped into its address
space.
OK, so this is a
little bit tricky
because I presented this as
though A and B referenced
totally different
pieces of memory.
So, I sort of have
told you so far only
about modules that
are referencing
disjoint sets of memory.
But in fact these page
maps, right, they just
reside in memory somewhere.
And it's just fine
if I, for example,
have multiple modules that
are able to reference, that
have the same physical
addresses mapped
into their virtual
address space.
So it's very likely
that I might want
to have something down
here at the bottom
that both A and B can access.
So, this might be stuff
that's shared between A and B.
I can map that into
both A and B's memory.
In the same way, what I'm
going to do is I'm going to map
these page maps, which
are also stored in memory
into all of the page maps into
the kernel's address space.
So the kernel is going to be
able to reference the address
spaces of all the modules.
And the kernel is
also going to keep
a little table of all the page
maps for all of the currently
running programs on the system.
So these are, for example,
page maps for A and B.
And this is a list
of all the maps
that are currently
running in the system.
So what's going to
happen, now what
can happen is because the kernel
is allowed to change the PMAR,
and because it knows
about the location of all
the other address spaces that
are in the system, when it
wants to start running one of
these programs that's running
in the system, it
can change the value
of the PMAR to be sort of the
PMAR for A or the PMAR to B.
And, it can manipulate
all the values
of the registers
in the system so
that you can start executing
code for one of these.
You can switch between
one of these two modules.
So the actual process of
switching between which module
is currently running.
We're going to focus
on that more next time.
So, don't worry too much
if you don't understand
the details of how you
actually switch from executing
one program to another program.
But, you can see
that the kernel can
switch which address
space is currently
active by simply
manipulating the value
of this PMAR register.
Furthermore, the
kernel can do things
like it can create a new map.
So the kernel can
simply allocate
one of these new tables,
and it can set up
a mapping from a set
of virtual addresses
to a set of physical
addresses so that you
can create a new address
space that a new module can
start executing within.
Similarly, the kernel can do
things like allocate new memory
into one of these addresses.
So it can map some
additional virtual addresses
into real physical memory so
that when one of these modules,
say for example, requests
additional memory to execute,
the kernel can add that memory,
add an entry into the table
so that that new memory that the
program has requested actually
maps into a valid,
physical address.
OK, so the question,
of course, then is,
so you can see the value of
having this kernel module.
But the question is,
how do we communicate
between these modules that
are running these user level
modules that are running, and
the kernel module that the user
modules need to invoke, for
example, request new memory.
So the way that we
are going to do this
is just like we've done
everything else in this lecture
so far: by adding a
little bit of extra,
by changing the processor
just a little bit.
So in particular, what
we're going to do --
What we're going to do is
to is to add this notion
of a supervisor call.
Call that SVC.
So a supervisor call is
simply a special instruction
that is on the processor
that invokes the kernel.
So when the supervisor call
instruction gets executed,
it's going to set up the state
of these PMAR and user kernel
bit instructions so that the
kernel can begin executing.
The supervisor
call is also going.
But when the supervisor call
instruction is executed,
we need to be a little bit
careful because we also
need to decide somehow
which code within the kernel
we want to begin executing when
the supervisor call instruction
gets executed, right?
So what the supervisor
call instruction does
is it accepts a parameter which
is the name of a so-called gate
function.
So a gate function is a
well defined entry point
into another module that can be
used to invoke a piece of code
in that other module.
So, for example,
the kernel is going
to have a particular
gate function which
corresponds to allocating
additional memory for a module.
So when a user program executes
an instruction, supervisor
call, to gate say
for example, this
might be some memory
allocation code,
this special
instruction is going
to do the following things.
First it's going to set the
user kernel bit to kernel.
Then it's going to set the
value of the PMAR register
to the kernel page map.
It's going to save the program
counter for the currently
executing instruction,
and then it's
going to set the program counter
to be the address of the gate
function, OK?
So we've introduced a special
new processor instruction
that takes these steps.
So when this
instruction is executed,
we essentially switch into
executing within the kernel's
address space.
OK, and this
kernel, and we begin
executing within the
kernel address space
at the address of this gate
function within the kernel's
address space.
OK, so what this
has done is this
is a well defined entry point.
If the program tries to
execute this instruction
with the name of a gate
function that doesn't exist,
then that program is
going to get an error
when it tries to do that.
So the program can only
name gate functions
that actually correspond
to real things
that the operating system can
do, that the kernel can do.
And so, the kernel is then
going to be invoked and take
that action that
was requested of it.
On return, essentially,
so when the kernel
finishes executing
this process, when
it finishes executing this, say,
memory allocation instruction,
we are just going to
reverse this step.
So we are just going
to set the PMAR
to be, we're going
to set the PMAR back
to the user's program.
We are going to set the user
kernel bit back into user mode.
And then we're going to jump
back to the saved return
address that we saved
here, the saved program
counter address from
the user's program.
So when the program finishes,
when the kernel finishes
executing this
service instruction,
the control will
just return back
to the program in the
place where the program
needs to begin executing.
OK, so now using this gate,
so using this notion of,
so what we've seen so far
now is the ability for the,
we can use the virtual
memory abstraction
in order to protect the memory
references of two modules
from each other.
And we see when we have this
notion of the kernel that
can be used to,
for example, that
can be used to manage these
address spaces to allocate
new memory to these address
spaces, and in general,
to sort of manage
these address spaces.
So this kernel is
also going to allow
us to do exactly what
we set out trying to do,
which is to act as the so-called
trusted intermediary between,
say for example, a client
and a server running
on the same machine.
OK, so I trust that intermediary
is just a piece of code.
So suppose we have a
client and a server, right,
and these are two
pieces of code written
by two different developers.
Maybe the two developers
don't necessarily
trust that the other
developer has written
a piece of code that's 100%
foolproof because it doesn't
have any bugs.
But both of those
developers may be
willing to say that
they will trust
that the kernel is
properly written
and doesn't have any bugs in it.
And so they are willing
to allow the kernel
to sit in between
those two programs
and make sure that
neither of them
has any bad interactions
with each other.
So let's see how we can use
this kernel, the kernel combined
with virtual memory in
order to be able to do this.
So suppose this is our kernel.
So the idea is that
this kernel running has,
so suppose we have
two processes A and B
that want to communicate
with each other in some way.
And, we already said that we
don't want these two processes
to be able to directly reference
into each other's memory
because that makes them
dependent on each other.
It means that if
there's a bug in A,
that A can overwrite some
memory in B's address space
and cause B to crash.
So, that's a bad thing.
So instead, what we are going
to do is we're going to create,
well, one thing we
can do is to create
a special set of
these supervisor calls
that these two modules can use
to interact with each other.
So in particular, we
might within the kernel
maintain a queue of messages
that these two programs are
exchanging with each
other, a list of messages
that they're exchanging.
And then, suppose A is,
we're going to call this guy,
A is a producer.
He's creating messages.
And B is a consumer.
A can call some function
like Put which will --
supervisor call like Put --
which will cause a data item
to be put on this queue.
And then sometime later, B can
call this supervisor call Get,
and pull this value
out of the queue, OK?
So in this way, the
producer and the consumer
can interact with each other.
They can exchange
data with each other
and because we have
this gate interface,
this well-defined gate
interface with these Put
and Get calls being
invoked by the kernel,
the kernel can be
very careful, just
like in the case of the
client and server running
on two different machines.
In this case, the kernel can
carefully verify that these put
and get commands that these two
different modules are calling
actually are correctly formed,
that the parameters are valid,
that they're referring to
valid locations in memory.
And therefore, the
kernel can sort of
ensure that these
two modules don't
do malicious things
to each other
or cause each other to break.
So this is an example
here of something
that's like an
inter-process communication.
So you saw, for
example, you've seen
an instance of
inter-process communication
when he studied the UNIX paper.
We talked about pipes,
and a pipe abstraction,
and how that works.
Well, pipes are
sort of something
that's implemented
by the kernel in UNIX
as a way for two programs to
exchange data with each other.
And, there's lots of
these kinds of services
that our people tend
to push into the kernel
that the kernel provides to the
other applications, the modules
that are running, so
that these modules can,
for example, interact
with hardware or interact
with each other.
So commonly within
a kernel, you'd
find things like a file system,
an interface to the network,
and you might, for example,
find things like an interface
to the graphics hardware.
OK, there is some sort of --
so if you look at what's
actually within a kernel,
there is a huge
amount of code that's
going into these kernels.
So I think we talked earlier
about how the Linux operating
system is many millions
of lines of code.
If you go look at
the Linux kernel,
the Linux kernel
is probably today
on the order of about 5 million
lines of code, most of which,
say two thirds of
which, is related
to these so-called
device drivers that
manage this low-level hardware.
So this kernel has
gotten quite large.
And one of the side effects
of the kernel getting large
is that maybe it's harder
to trust it, right?
May be you sort of
have less confidence
that all the code in the
kernel is actually correct.
And you can imagine that if
you don't trust the kernel then
the computer is not going to
be as stable as you like to be.
And this is one argument for why
Windows crashes all the time is
because it has all
these drivers in it
and these drivers
aren't necessarily all
perfectly written.
There are tens of millions
of lines of code in Windows,
and some of them crash
some of the time,
and that causes the whole
computer to come down.
So there's a tension in the
operating systems community
about whether you should execute
these things, you should keep
these things look the
file system or graphics
system within the kernel or
whether you should move them
outside as separate services,
which can be invoked
in the same way, for example,
that A and B interact
with each other, by having some
data structure that's stored
within the kernel that buffers
the requests between, say,
the service and this, say, for
example the graphics service
and the users' programs that
want to interact with it.
OK, so that's
basically it for today.
What I've shown you
is, well, actually we
have a few more minutes.
Sorry.
[LAUGHTER] I know you're
all getting up to leave,
but so, OK, I just
want to quickly touch
on one last topic which
is that, so, what I've
shown you so far
is how we can use
the notion of virtual memory
in order to protect the data,
protect two programs
from each other
so that they can't
necessarily interact
with each other's data.
But there is some situations
in which we might actually
want to have two
programs able to share
some data with each other.
So I don't know if
you guys remember,
but when Hari was
lecturing earlier,
he talked about how
there are libraries
that get linked into programs.
And one of the common
ways that libraries
are structured these days is
a so-called shared library.
So a shared library
is something that
is only stored in one
location in physical memory.
But multiple
different modules that
are executing on that
system can call functions
within that shared library.
So in order to make
this work, right, we
need to have mapped the memory
for the shared library that
has all the functions that
these other modules want
to call into the address spaces
for both of these modules
so that they can actually
execute the code that's there.
So the virtual memory
system makes it very trivial
to do this.
So suppose I have my address
space for some function, A,
and I have my address
space for some function, B.
And suppose that function
A references library
one and module B references
libraries one and two.
OK, so using the virtual
memory system, suppose we have,
so this is our physical memory.
So, suppose that module
A, program A, is loaded.
And when it's
loaded, the program
that runs other programs,
the loader in this case,
is going to load this
shared library, one,
as it loads for program A.
So, it's going to first
load the code for A,
and then it's going to
load the code for one.
And, these things are going to
be sitting in memory somewhere.
So, within A's
address space we're
going to have the code for
A is going to be mapped
and the code for one
is going to be mapped.
Now, when B executes, right,
what we want to avoid,
so the whole purpose
of shared libraries
is to make it so that when
two programs are running
and they both use
the same library
there aren't two copies
of that library that
are in memory using twice
as much of the memory up,
right, because there's all these
libraries that all computer
programs share.
For example, on Linux
there's the libc library
that implements all of
the standard functions
that people use in C programs.
If there's 50 programs written
in C on your Linux machine,
you don't want to have 50 copies
of this libc library in memory.
You want to have just one.
So what we want is that
when module B gets loaded,
we want it to map this
code that's already
been mapped into the address
space of A into its memory
as well, OK?
And then, of course,
we're going to have
to load additional memory for B
itself, and for the library two
which A hasn't already loaded.
So now, those are
going to be loaded
into some additional
locations in B's memory,
are going to be loaded into
some additional locations
in the physical memory and
mapped into A's memory.
So, this is just showing
that we can actually
use this notion
of address spaces,
in addition to
using it to isolate
two modules from
each other so they
can't refer to each
other's memory,
we can also use it as a way
to allow two modules to share
things with each other.
And in particular, this is a
good idea in the case of things
like shared libraries
where we have two things,
both programs need to be
able to read the same data.
So they could use
this to do that.
OK, so what we saw today was
this notion of virtual memory
and address spaces.
We saw how we have
the kernel that's
a trusted intermediary
between two applications.
What we're going
to see next time
is how we can take this notion
of virtualizing a computer.
We saw how to virtualize
the memory today.
Next time we're going to see
how we virtualize the processor
in order to create
the abstraction
of multiple processors
running on just one
single, physical
piece of hardware.
So I'll see you tomorrow.